le chef de l'état qui veut relancer
l'apprentissage de l'allemand et les
ministres qui prennent des cours
d'anglais l'anglais langue
incontournable lors des réunions
européennes et internationales
certains de nos politiques n'hésitent
pas à prendre des cours particuliers
pour rattraper leur retard et 1000 ils
en sont yann one c'est connu on parle
beaucoup à l'assemblée mais partout
anglais arrière tout progresse
l'action a les plus grosses koshiro
caleiras depuis toujours les hommes
politiques français et l'anglais
c'est un poème show man show et the most
of pain les exceptions tout de même
comme jacques chirac reçu ici par larry
king en 95
au parlement européen les journalistes
gilles langlais des français franchement
quand tu attends il parle couramment il
a des autres c'est entendu moscovite si
l'ancien ministre européens de la france
est elle très bien pourtant même à des
postes clés comme celui de commissaire
européen
l'anglais ce n'est pas toujours ça le
secrétaire d'état à l'assurance maladie
lui a pris les choses en main
aujourd'hui les particuliers toutes les
semaines wii wii fit state mais je suis
d'accord avec cette phrase c'est en se
rendant des sommets européens que xavier
bertrand a pris conscience de ses
lacunes en anglais
à chaque fois qu'il ya une pause il ya
ce qu'on appelle les coffee break et là
on échange de façon un peu naturelle de
façon sympa et c'est là aussi qu'on peut
faire passer des idées
hélas si vous n'avez pas d'interprète
vous êtes complètement perdu un standing
son but se passe et traducteur lors des
prochaines rencontres aux rebelles